so what advice would i have for someone
who wants to be an entrepreneur
so everyone's path is different so take
anything i have to say with a grain of
salt but you know a lot of folks think
of entrepreneurship as hey i have a new
idea for business whether it's a
restaurant or a new technology company a
new social network whatever it might be
and they they put a lot of emphasis on
the idea itself and i think most
entrepreneurs would tell you that a lot
more depends not only on the idea but
the execution of the idea and really
just how ready is the world is the
market for your idea and so
my advice would be
especially if you're early in your
career try to build as many skills as
you can and to be an entrepreneur you
have to be a little bit of a
jack-of-all-trades so know your finance
know your accounting know your marketing
and you don't have to know it
necessarily academically but know it
intuitively pay attention to how other
people are doing it
think about your strategy and
wherever your area of interest is if
it's to start a restaurant get to know
that business really really really well
work at a restaurant at all levels if
your goal is to work in tech work at
some tech companies get to know that
really really well get to know not just
the technology not just the product
management not just the design but the
sales aspect of it get to know the
management aspect of it and the whole
time that you're building yourself up
that you're working in industry and
learning these various skills make sure
that you have some time to fiddle
the best entrepreneurial ideas
that i've seen are the ones where folks
get to know a space well through their
craft and then they have an idea and
then they're able to have a little bit
of time to test out that idea not only
build it not only prototype it but put
it out there somehow and see how the
market responds and if the market is
responding very favorably if people are
saying wow i want more of this how can i
get it then i think you're on to
something and all of those skills that
you would have built up over those many
years not only will they help you
execute on the idea
but they'll help you convince other
people that you're ready to execute on
the idea which is maybe just as
important potential investors people
that you need to uh co-found your
venture with uh and also you know my
last point is is know what your weak
points are as you experience all of
these dimensions of starting a business
if you know that hey maybe the marketing
isn't my thing know that and then you
can find someone who's good at it who
can compliment you if you're like hey i
like the entrepreneurial side but
scaling up a business isn't my cup of
tea find great operators who can help
you scale it up so that's my two cents
take it all with a grain of salt